[Music]
you don't have to say though I found
most annoying about the debate
I thought the split-screen format was
very distracting I don't know yeah take
a look at this thing yeah Obama and
Romney were split-screen so while one
candidate was talking you watched the
other guy reacting you couldn't help but
see him reacting to everything the other
guy was saying so it's distracting Alan
put Andy shot up next to mine you see
what I'm saying if I did this during the
show it just seems like it would be
awkward it which is somes an awkward
format to me I I don't know it seems
kind of cool to me : alright we'll leave
it up I guess when one person's talking
it's fascinating to see how the other
person reacts actually I think it's a
window into how the speaker is really
perceived by one of his coworkers
it's a great indicator of the person's
true status oh absolutely Conan you know
a lot of subtle cues to a person's real
feelings I mean what they don't want
other people to see you can be discerned
from their facial expressions their
gestures and their body language sure
what somebody reveals with their posture
and especially their hands can shine a
light on their inner feelings about a
person oh definitely I mean you know
sometimes hand gestures are the most
expressive and honest formal
hey I couldn't agree with you more old
friend I'm glad we tried this
interesting experiment
[Applause]
amazing show tonight
Actress New York Times bestselling
author Jenny McCarthy is here
[Applause]
director of the film Star Trek for oh my
god
producer of the television whoa producer
of the television series revolution and
person of interests the deviously
ingenious JJ Abrams
[Applause]
[Music]
you didn't do any of this at rehearsal
you perv